The Ballot Box every vote counts and
sanon bonmi is out in a squatter
community on the edge of Bangkok chasing
support
voters here have very real concerns the
rising cost of living most live far
below the poverty line
but Sanam says there's a greater threat
parties who are threatening to reform
the monarchy the country is in danger I
think this is a very sensitive time
especially when you have gullible and
impressionable young people who only
take information from one side
the party that has governed for the past
four years is not doing well its
candidate general pro at Wong xuan is
seen as out of touch
his partner in government and the
current prime minister General prayer
chanocha has been active on the campaign
Trail but the man who led a military
coup in 2014 has been Keen to remind
voters that the key to the Future
is stability
our nation religion and the monarchy are
the reason why we have peace today and
people keep asking what's the point of
having a military the military is here
to maintain peace if there's a crisis
those are ominous words prompted by the
potential success of opposition parties
if they win by a significant margin it
could threaten the systems of government
the coup makers put in place
that military coming back into the
political scene is always a possibility
but how many uh what we call how many
years are they going to willing to wait
or how many months are they willing to
wait it's something that we have to keep
a very close eye on there may be other
threats to the result of Sunday's vote
the current Constitution put in place by
the military affords powers to the
Senate the election commission and the
Constitutional court that may impact the
outcome the pathway into Parliament may
not be cleared on Election Day the
election commission has already launched
an inquiry into the party that's on top
of the polls per tie for possible
populist policies but that could lead to
disqualification in the final week of
campaigning the Prime Minister has
looked bullish finishing his rallies to
A rousing Chorus of the royal Anthem his
message is clear only he and his allies
can protect Thailand and the monarchy
from the threat of those who offer
reform
Tony Chang Al Jazeera Bangkok